[Music]
this
okay
welcome um to our press conference
following the first day of our european
council the conclusions will be
published shortly
and i give the floor to the present of
the european council
thank you uh good evening or good night
uh everyone we we had tonight an
important meeting of the european
council the first topic on the agenda
was related to the situation ukraine
there are two important elements that we
have addressed first one the support for
ukraine very important to we express and
to reiterate our strong commitment it
means that
we are taking important steps by
clarifying how we will address
the financial support and we know that
ukraine needs financial support for uh
for being able to run the country it
means that they need micro financial
9 billion euros is confirmed by the
european council and also to start
all the programs that will be needed for
the rebuilding of the country we want to
engage with all the partners with the
experts with the ukraine authorities but
also with third countries and with the
international community this is the
first topic and we had the occasion one
more time
to listen carefully to the message
expressed by the president vladimir
zelesti at the beginning of our european
council's meetings
[Music]
stopped
this is a remarkable achievement by the
european council i would like to thank
all the colleagues who have participated
in this meeting because we need we need
political leadership in those
extraordinary difficult times we do not
underestimate all the difficulties we
know that we need it
a few weeks before we we were able to
take such a decision but i think it's a
very strong signal that we sent today
because the recent hours recent days
there were speculations about the risk
for a lack of unity of european union's
unity and i think that more than ever
it's important to show that we are able
to be strong that we are able to be
firm that we are able to be tough in
order to defend our values to defend our
interests and against i would like to
wait with my gratitude for all the
colleagues who are able to take together
this strong decision and to express a
united message towards ukraine towards
russia but also towards the european uh
union citizens and the rest of the world
thank you
thank you president madam president you
have a friend thank you so much indeed
we had a very good discussion uh tonight
and uh i'm very glad that the leaders
were able to agree in principle um on
the six uh sanctions package
um this is very important thanks to this
council should now be able to finalize a
ban on almost 90 percent
of all russian oil imports by the end of
the year this is an important step
forward
the remaining 10
on these one we will soon return to the
issue
of these remaining 10 percent pipeline
oil
i want to note that other elements in
the package are also important
it's the de-swifting of the spare bank
the spare bank is the biggest russian
bank
with 37 percent
so this is good that we now de-swift the
spare bank
there's a ban on insurance and
reinsurance of russian ships by eu
companies
a ban on providing russian companies
with a whole range of business services
and very important the suspension of
broadcasting in the european union of
three further russian state outlets
that were very typically
spreading broadly the misinformation
that we have witnessed over the last
weeks and months
and then we had a very good discussion
indeed also on ukraine
and here
i want to emphasize two elements it's
mainly the financial support that
ukraine needs urgently now
as you know that as you know
ukraine needs by now
per month round about 5 billion euros to
maintain the basic services that is
paying pensions paying salaries
and
as i said the basic services that are
necessary
there we agreed that on one hand we take
note of the very good result of g7
that put nine and a half billion already
on the table
seven and a half billion of those are
american contributions
and 1 billion in g7 by germany and
grants but we think that of course the
european union has to carry its fair
share too
and therefore we are working on a
mechanism to have an extraordinary macro
financial assistance package of 9
billion
which we will work on now in the next
week
how to put it in place
and my last point but
very important too
we discussed intensively the question of
the reconstruction of ukraine
and here we all know that we will invest
we will have a large amount of work
colossal as president zielenski said for
the reconstruction of ukraine
i think it is important that we are very
well organized on that and therefore it
was good um that
we could discuss the proposal of the
commission in the council to create a
platform
where we can channel all the
international initiatives be it oecd or
g20 or imf or world bank the european
efforts our american friends for example
to
be clear together on the direction of
travel
to raise the necessary investment
but also to be very clear that
investment comes with reform
reform of
the
administrative capacity
the judicial independence to fight
corruption
to create a conducive environment for
the business sector
here it is important that we really
stand together
to give ukraine a fair chance to rise
from the ashes and to be able to really
leap frog forward uh what reconstruction
is concerned in investment but also in
the improvement of the state of ukraine
thank you
thank you madam president we'll be
taking very few well very few questions
considering the lateness of the hour
martina you were first
yes you have to stand up and and go to
the stand sorry
sorry it's sort of made for taller
people than me hi uh madina stevens um
from the new york times thanks very much
for this um regarding the assessment of
ten percent or one-third
uh of
what exactly the numbers are
according to european commission
assessments on the pipeline oil that is
now exempt there seems to be a
discrepancy between that assessment
and our understanding is we haven't seen
the tax yet that you received some
verbal assurances by country countries
that receive oil by pipeline that they
in fact do intend to phase that out very
quickly for example we heard from the
germans that they will actually phase it
out by the end of the year can you
please speak to assurances hungary
offered if any to do the same and do you
think that despite the importance of
this measure the symbolic loss of
hungary's um sort of attachment to the
measure does uh take some of the shine
off that measure thank you
there is a there is a clear decision
taken at the departure level tonight it
means it will ban
the russian all and 75 percent is the
decision that we have uh taken because
there is a temporary exception for
the oil
that comes through a pipeline to to to
the eu and 90
is based on the fact that there are
international statements made by germany
and poland that's why it means 90 by the
end of the year that will be that will
be
targeted is this one element and it's a
temporary exception it means that we we
want to
revert to the european council as soon
uh as possible in order to address uh
this temporary exception and to make
sure that will be able to to target uh
all uh the russian oil and it's also in
line with the decision taken a few
months ago in paris uh the summit in
versailles when we had decided
to end our dependencies on russian
fossil fuels a few weeks ago i had the
occasion it was six weeks or
eight weeks ago in the european
parliament to share my personal opinion
and i said publicly that i was convinced
that sooner or later we'll also target
the fossil fuels at the energy sector
this is a huge step in the right
direction and i'm very pleased that we
are able tonight to send a strong
political signal in line
with the credibility of the european
union a strong support for ukraine and
we try
to sanction russia the kremlin as much
as we can
yes indeed um what are the figures um
two-thirds of the oil that we have in
the european union is seabourn
and one-third is pipeline
and here we have the druzhba pipeline
this is the one and only pipeline
for russian oil
and there is the northern part providing
to poland and germany
and the southern part going uh to
hungary and later on slovakia
and indeed
as i said one-third is the pipeline oil
as we have a clear
political
statement
by poland and by germany
that they will as the others
the seabourn oil
wind down
the russian oil till the end of the year
we have covered overall 90 percent of
russian oil
being wind down
in in this time frame
now left over is the around about 10 or
11 percent
that are covered by the
southern uh dushba
and indeed here we have agreed agreed
this is for the moment being exempted we
have agreed to uh that the council will
revert to the topic as soon as possible
in one way or the other
so
this is a topic where we will come back
to
and
where we will still have to work on but
it is a big step forward what we did
today
because indeed we now have gotten rid of
coal and this was already very difficult
now we have basically the political
agreement how to phase out oil in a
clear time frame
and we started tonight and we will
report tomorrow to discuss the big
energy package repower eu
that the commission tabled which is the
basis to be able over time to completely
diversify away from russian fossil fuels
that is our goal and therefore
we have now a very clear roadmap on the
table
thank you madam president
yanis you were next
thank you janis paleolos from kathmarini
uh on the subject of assurances can you
tell us the prime minister of hungary
said today
that he needed more assurances in order
to come to this political agreement and
now we have this political agreement on
the sixth package can you speak to what
assurances he was given to be able to
agree
thank you
an important element related to the the
risk of interruption and in case of uh
interruption and if the interruption is
not the consequence of a a decision
taken by a government of one of the
landlord the landlocked country it means
that we have decided to take the
appropriate measures you know to react
and to make sure that we will protect
the security of supply this is a very
important element that we have decided
to take into account and i think this is
fair because it's important on the one
hand uh to to to decide to be clear uh
to sanction the kremlin to sanction
russia but it's uh on the other hand
this is important to to take into
account the level playing field but also
uh the secretary of supply yeah
thank you lawrence you have the last
question for tonight
thanks a lot laurence norman from the
wall street journal um
mr michelle
you just used the word fair
what first of all what is there in this
agreement tonight
that doesn't prevent hungary exempting
itself
from a pipeline
ban on oil for years you talk about as
soon as possible
what is there that what is there to
prevent hungary maintaining that
exemption for years is there anything
that we can do about that and secondly
on fairness on level playing field
hungary gets an exemption
on pipelines which is pretty much all of
all of its oil
hungary gets the right in an emergency
to buy
russian oil from vessels
where
has hungary given anything what is the
fairness
in that deal
first i think it is fair for the
european union
the european union citizen
to understand that we take into account
the security of supply which is an
important priority for our households
and for for the businesses and this is
why it was so difficult to wish the
agreement because
certainly for the first package of
sanctions it was less less painful and
less risky for for us now this is a
difficult topic because this is about
the energy sector and that's why it's
more complex it's more sensitive it's
more it's more difficult it's one one
first element second element uh we have
decided at the level of the ambassadors
uh to to to to do everything at the
technical level which is needed in order
to to to phase out our dependencies and
even to end our dependencies on russian
fossil fuels an additional element
because you spoke and you mentioned
hungary but in fact the decision of
station tonight is not a decision for
hungary it's a decision you know to take
into account the situation of the lent
locked countries uh and it's more uh
than hungary and in the following hours
it will take place on wednesday
the ambassadors will have the task to
take the legal decision in order to
implement the political principles that
you have agreed on tonight this is a
strange and precise political decision
that we have taken and it will be
implemented in the in the legal form in
the following hours it will take place
on wednesday
let me add two points that
will show that
there is
clarity that fairness will prevail
to
replace uh in the southern rushva the
oil russian oil that goes to hungary
there is in place in croatia the adria
pipeline
that
where we can
increase
the prime minister explained it to us
tonight the
capacity so that it will over time
deliver
other oil than the russian oil
be able to deliver that to hungary
the time that is needed for this
capacity increase was around about 45 to
60 days so it's
in a reasonable time frame
and it needs some investment
and
objectively for this landlocked country
hungary
also the refineries
will have to be updated because the
russian oil is of different quality than
the adriatic pipeline oil
so
it is good to have a certain amount
of time and activity
um to fulfill all these criteria so that
hungary can really switch
off
the russian oil
and as a second element which i want to
emphasize again it's very clear in the
council conclusions that we will revert
to this topic one way or the other and
there are means otherwise also to
accelerate
this procedure
thank you very much for joining us thank
you presidents
see you tomorrow at 9 30 we will start
again